ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Hi.
In this session, we'll talk
about Data QnA, a new Google
Cloud Service that Veolia is
using to democratize access
to BigQuery.
I'm Abhishek Kashyap,
product manager for Data QnA
and BigQuery ML at Google Cloud.
FABRICE NICO: Hello,
I'm Fabrice Nico.
Thanks a lot to Google
for the invitation.
I've been working at
Veolia for nine years.
I'm part of the IT department.
I'm in charge of all subject
related to data and robotics
object for the group
function support.
And my main customers are
finance, procurement, HR,
legal departments.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP: Thank you,
Fabrice, for joining us today.
In terms of the
agenda, we'll start
by introducing Data QnA,
which as the name suggests,
is a natural language based
question-answer service
for getting insights
on your BigQuery data
by just typing a question,
wherever you are.
We will follow it up
with our discussion
on Veolia, which will
be led by Fabrice.
Let us start with Data QnA.
As I mentioned, I'm
a product manager
for BigQuery ML, which is
another product at Google Cloud
to do machine learning.
We have a product dashboard
for various metrics
that I need to track to
do my day to day job.
But I do have a lot of ad hoc
questions every now and then,
because our dashboard cannot
contain all the charts that I
might need in the future.
As I show in this
example, when I
want to know how many on
demand customers used BigQuery
ML last week, I have to
go find their ticket,
and their developer has to add
a new chart to the dashboard.
That takes almost
two days, which
delays me in doing my work.
But more than that, it is a
distraction for the developer,
as they have to stop
doing their day job
and take care of
this simple chart.
With Data QnA, now I'm
just able to go and ask
that question using text and
get the answer right away.
And I do not have to bother
the developer whenever
I have a question like this.
So what we are doing
here is democratizing
access to insights
by enabling users
to ask questions in natural
language on BigQuery data.
When we say democratization,
let us see what it entails.
In this case, I could ask a
question in free form text.
I did not have to know the
underlying data at all.
I could just talk in what we
call a business speak, rather
than data speak,
which is what you
need for a broad set
of users to use this.
There is information
provided, which in this case
is an interpretation of
the question that I read,
and that formed trust
for me, in knowing
that it is answering
what I asked for
and the answer is correct.
Fourth, I can go access it
in that interface I work in.
In this case, this
was Google Sheets.
I, as a business user, am
working in spreadsheets a lot,
so I did not have to go open a
SQL editor and type it in there
to get the answer I needed.
And finally, the BigQuery
governance and access policies
that have been defined are all
taken care of automatically.
There is no chance that
somebody without access
to this confidential
customer information
would be able to go and
get access to this data
from this new natural
language interface.
The vision for Data QnA
is for any business user
to go to their interface
of choice, which
could be a chatbot, a
spreadsheet, or a BI platform,
ask a question through
natural language
and get an answer back.
Data QnA parses the
question that is asked,
identifies the intent
and the entities,
matches those to the underlying
data, generates a SQL,
and returns an answer
to the end user.
And from this, we see
three key benefits.
One, any business user
with the appropriate access
can go ask a question
and get insights
when they need
it, without having
to wait for somebody else to
add a chart to the dashboard.
Second, the BI
team, which usually
responds to these ad hoc
requests, can be freed up.
And they can focus on
more critical tasks.
And finally, we enable access
through multiple interfaces.
So it is available
wherever users work.
During the alpha,
this is natively
available through Google
Sheets and BigQuery web UI.
We also have APIs,
which would allow
you to embed Data QnA into a
chatbot or your own custom UI,
so you can make it
available in whatever tool
your business users work in.
Now let us see
Data QnA in action.
We have some open source
data from Instacart
that contains
transaction information,
along with information
on the items,
the location, and
the member loyalty.
We set up Data QnA once,
and we will show you
how you can ask questions
and get insights
on three different interfaces,
a Google chat chatbot, Google
Sheets, or the BigQuery web UI.
The experience on
Sheets is similar.
Sheets has a feature called
Connected Sheets that
allows you to connect
to a BigQuery table
and analyze that table through
the spreadsheet itself.
With Data QnA, you can start
asking questions on that data
as well.
In this case, the
UI is richer, and we
are able to even
auto suggest entities
that help users get
a better experience
and make less errors in
writing these questions.
To illustrate some of the
more advanced capabilities,
an example question here is
to compare the average price
between two products, which are
values in one of the columns
in the underlying data.
And as you can see, we do return
the SQL as well for a more
advanced user to validate.
And there is a
feedback button, using
which a user can signal whether
the answer was correct or not.
And all of this
information is passed
in to the person who set up Data
QnA, who can view this feedback
and improve the service
for the end user.
The third demo is
on the BigQuery UI.
We have SQL analysts who are
proficient in SQL who usually
can use the BigQuery UI.
However, as you can see from
one of these example queries,
some of the queries
can take time to write.
So we have added Data QnA
as a productivity function
to the BigQuery UI.
So you can just type a question.
It will generate a
query for you that you
can populate into the
SQL editor and continue
to edit it or run it as is.
To summarize the features that
we just showed, with Data QnA,
you can ask a question
in free form text
without having to load
the underlying data.
But you can use
business terminology.
Using Google knowledge graph,
we understand common synonyms.
We auto suggest column
names and data values.
These are available
through the API.
We do accept typos, so if a user
makes an error, we do not fail.
We come back with
the right value.
And if we do not understand
the question fully,
we return a clarification.
We are optimized for
precision versus coverage.
So if we are not
sure, we'll just ask,
did you mean x or
did you mean y?
We have a setup that enables
answering incomplete questions.
As an example, if I
just said top products
and did not mention
I wanted my revenue,
revenue could have been
set up as a default metric.
And we will return an answer
just by saying top products.
If your tables are
date partitioned,
we do query the right partition
to optimize the costs.
And for all BigQuery
governments and cost
controls that you
have set up, we
will work with those
out of the box.
I mentioned setup.
The reason we have a setup
component is twofold.
One, not all data is clean.
So we have many customers
who have created views
for powering end user
dashboards, which
have their clean data that is
trusted by the organization.
Data QnA can be enabled
on all of those views
and provide the right
answer to the end users.
Second, we do want you
to add business domain
specific synonyms to the
individual columns in your data
so that business users do
not have to ask questions
using column names, which as
we know, could be anything.
But they can use the
business terminology
they use day in and day out.
Finally, we show reports of
all questions being asked
and the results as
well as the status,
whether it was
successful or it failed,
in a dashboard to the person
who sets up these tables
or views for Data QnA.
So you can continuously monitor
these and improve the service
if something is
not being answered
or if some answer
does not look correct.
With that, I will hand
it over to Fabrice
to talk about Veolia.
FABRICE NICO: Hi,
Fabrice speaking.
Thanks a lot, Abhi,
for your introduction.
I'm here today to tell
you a story about how
we support our businesses
with innovative and digital
solutions.
More precisely, how we reached
the target with Google support
and a little bit of imagination.
The touch of imagination
is called ISA,
but we will see this idea later.
For those we don't
know Veolia yet,
we provide services around
three main businesses
around the world--
water, waste, and energy are
the heart of our activities
operated by 178,000 employees
through five continents.
Veolia's mission is
to resource the world.
We contribute to developing
access to resources,
preserving and
prepositioning them.
An example is 98 million people
supplied with safe drinking
water, 42 million
people provided
with collection services.
Or again, 41 billion megawatts
of power produced per year.
Veolia's strategic program
is called Impact 2023,
and the objective is to make
Veolia a benchmark company
for ecological conservation.
To support this program,
the Veolia IT department
has started, since
over the past year,
multiple digital
automation programs.
In example, in 2013,
with [INAUDIBLE] adoption
for the entire group.
Or in 2017, we have digital
workplace setting up
and public cloud adoption.
And finally in 2019,
with bringing data
value to help businesses.
Strong IT foundation, built
so far by IT departments,
support objectives of Impact
2023 strategic program.
To be concrete and give you
an example of the difficulty
we've got within Veolia,
and I think concern a lot
of companies around
the world, I would
like to tell you a story
about how we can democratize
the information access.
In my previous life,
when I was a consultant,
to find valuable
information was like to be
a hunter in a jungle.
If you don't have
the right networking,
it's fairly an
impossible mission.
And finally, if you
catch it, this one
will be out of date or
only readable by an expert.
Offering right information
to do it right population
at the right moment,
it's really a challenge.
Who has never been
upset in meetings
not to get access
directly and quickly
to your own information?
To the crucial data essential
to the decision making.
I think about CFO
who want on demand
and immediately to access to
revenue or every day figures
for a specific organization.
Or service manager
who wants to find
quickly his remaining
budget anywhere, any time,
and from any devices.
Our dream is to democratize
access to information,
and that businesses are the
owner of their own information.
Information should be
available instantly
and on demand in a simple way.
And businesses must
be confident with it.
How do we succeed to fulfill
this business agreement?
Firstly, thanks to the Veolia
strategy and transformation
atmosphere, management
supported us
and pushed us to be
disruptive, and above all,
gave us the means and the tools
to meet the challenges related
to help transformation.
Secondly, thanks to the training
program and new IT skills,
digital communities have been
engaged by the IT department
to facilitate transformation.
And third, thanks to the
technical tools and partnership
with Google, platform as a
service and Google advice
sped up the availability
of our solution.
For instance, the
origin of our solution
comes from exchanges with
Google and from another document
dedicated to exploring
data with conversation.
This context allowed
us, in four months,
to offer a new digital solution
based on data lake concept
and chatbot to our businesses.
Our solution is
called ISA and is
to democratize and streamline
the access to the information,
in order to optimize the
decision making process.
Our concept is based
on three pillars--
information, self
service, and access, ISA.
Information,
because data is gold
and is essential to
the decision making.
Self service to let business
become self-sufficient
about data management.
And access to the information
needs to be implicitly
simple and quick.
Our ISA solution was put
in live a few months ago
and helped our business to adopt
the digital transformation.
A quick demo showing
how ISA works today.
User asks question
in our chat to ISA.
Answer is displayed on a
smart card with a web link.
When you click on
that, information
is published in a data
studio, prefiltered,
showing this information.
It's really [INAUDIBLE]
to consume information
in a simple way.
And after ISA, what's next?
We never stopped
our collaboration
with the Google team.
A new solution with QnA
looks like a good way
to upgrade our ISA solution.
This new and innovative
functionalities
will open up a data access view
to 360 degree to our business.
What are the main
functionalities
we tested and we found
interesting to be integrated
to ISA?
The first is the
capabilities of QnA
to offer, in real time, multiple
comparisons and analyses
based on data available from
the data lake environment.
Second one is to
produce in the tool
multiple charts based on
previous analyses related
to a question.
Benefit for us, if the
app needs acceleration
of the proposal of
several answers,
we would configuration
by the development team.
All of our great
features are based
on the multiple suggestions
offered by QnA [INAUDIBLE]
as an accelerator to the
adoption of the solution.
And last one, but not least,
QnA offers a configuration
console to enrich easily and
quickly the user experience.
And again, this feature
optimizes the time
to configure new answers.
In conclusion, integration
of QnA into our ISA solution
is eagerly awaited in order to
offer our businesses a new user
experience.
Thanks, Abhi, for
this time, and I'll
let you to carry on
this presentation.
ABHISHEK KASHYAP:
Thank you, Fabrice,
for providing us
with insights on how
you are planning to use Data
QnA to extend your ISA solution.
I'll wrap up by talking
about the pricing
and pointing to some
resources to get you started.
In terms of pricing,
Data QnA is not
going to have any
additional charge.
You can use Data QnA and ask
questions in natural language,
just like you could write a
SQL clearly and get an answer.
The only charge is going to
be for the underlying BigQuery
queries that get executed.
And you pay for them if you
use on demand pricing model.
If you use BigQuery
reservations,
you can use your slots as is.
When we set up, we
do index the data
values in the table to
provide capabilities,
like auto suggest.
That does carry a charge within
BigQuery or use your slots.
And finally, Data QnA
could require integration
with a chatbot or custom
UI, and you may also
need some help with the
set up and management
on individual data sets that
you want to enable Data QnA on.
We have partnered with some
key Google Cloud partners
to help you get started.
Please do reach out to them
if you are working with these
to get started with Data QnA.
A next step, if you are
interested in participating
in the alpha, please reach out
to your Google point of contact
or just fill the form
at the link below,
and we will get back to you.
Thank you for your time,
and have a great day.
FABRICE NICO: Thank you.